I'm Evan Carmichael walk to the edition
of ask Evan today i'm going to be
reviewing a website for one of our
readers kim stark so she's a YouTube
reader who wrote in saying great advice
we're video watch advise me with another
tool I would love some feedback on my
own site if you have a minute industrial
at MnDOT CA so we're going to go check
out the site and hopefully give Kim a
few ideas to help her make her website
better so we're going to go here load it
up so this is the website and at first
thought I'm thinking what you do and how
can you help me so you notice a lot of
website visitors were probably bounced
if you look at your own analytics and
this for everybody you'll see that a lot
of people won't even last 10 seconds on
your website they'll bounce and go back
and a lot of times it's because they
don't understand what is it you do and
they don't see a clear value and how you
can help them so I see here your name is
industrial demand solutions support when
and where you need it so this is ok but
I'd like to know a little bit more about
who you're targeting to see if this is
for me or not you talk a little bit more
about it here in your first paragraph
we're here to support any business with
their admin sales support marking some
requirements when they need on their own
site or on ours so if you're looking at
admin support for business I try to
include that somewhere in here just so
that if I'm a business owner and I come
to this site I I can quickly understand
that this is something that can
potentially help me so just improve that
a little bit I'd also probably look at
doing redesign on the website and again
it depends on what you do but if you're
here helping people as part of what you
do with their website so you're talking
about here on their own site or on yours
then i would i would probably invest a
little bit of money into a slightly
better website design here so a little
more professional look just so that you
can impress your clients who are coming
to you and it shows that you're more of
an expert you don't necessarily have to
be an expert in website design but if
you're talking about
helping people with their web sites even
just updated and being on the admin's
side it helps to have a more
professional look with the site you go
to a place like 99 designs com and get a
quick quote on improving your website
and get a whole bunch of different
designers coming in and giving you some
options so it definitely check that out
probably worth the investment I really
like a picture here so it's above the
fold obviously great smile I look
friendly easy to approach i would put
your name i don't see your name here
with the picture i don't see a place to
learn about you a little bit more this
would be great to have it as a video i
don't know how comfortable you are in
front of the camera but the picture is
great I want to learn a little bit more
about you and say who this is because
it's not it's not clear just from
looking at the homepage here I'd also
break up the text it's a lot of text
it's great that you have it in
paragraphs i guess but most people won't
read this so it's you want to make it as
easy as possible for people to interact
with your website so i would start with
having different bolded headers so a
couple words breaking up the paragraphs
a little bit more maybe some bullet
bullet points on here as well to make it
a little bit easier to read maybe a
little bit more content even just so
that you can rank in the search engines
because this is not going to be enough
content to get the page rank for any any
key term so i put a little bit more and
then scrolling down cole here we're here
to help the sprite bold the phone number
clear call to action that's awesome i
would probably put this in your header
too so put it up here somewhere phone
number just that if somebody hits your
page a lot of these guys may not be
tech-savvy but they have a pain point
with their company they need support
they may just see your name see your
great tagline that we're going to modify
to your phone number just give you a
call without even reading the rest of it
so you want to make the phone number
super easy for people you able to reach
out to you even the email you could put
up in here somewhere so it's easy for
people to find
let's learn a little bit more so we'll
click through let's click on the about
so the about us customer service and
type you work ethic this is great you
don't take vacation sick days this is
great to a lot of good points in here
just show me some of the benefits of
using it this is great we free of your
time so you can get back to doing what
you do best run your business I pipe
with that on bold want to know more
check us out of facebook linkedin and
twitter uh i would probably want to keep
people on the site here i don't i'm not
sure i'd want people to to go away to
facebook linkedin and twitter to learn
more i I'd want people to call call or
email or maybe you have some kind of
download that has a you know some case
studies that you've done I wouldn't want
people leaving the site here as I call
to action if I've if I've gone to your
home page and I was interested enough to
click on the about page and want to
learn more about you I I would want to
try to loop those guys in and get them
to reach out to you it's great you have
the phone number here and they still
might do it but I put that here you know
you could still have the links to your
social media but I wouldn't put that as
your main call to action is if people
want to learn more about it ducting the
phone number or the email next time if I
look at is you have any testimonials or
do you have any case studies and I see
there's a link here testimonials I
didn't see anything on the homepage so
this is great that you have all these
testimonials of people saying how you've
helped them I would definitely put one
or two of them on your homepage I maybe
not this whole thing is again this is
hard to read but I would put it on your
homepage so quickly people can see that
you know you're not just some startup
admin person because that's the
challenge is you're going up against a
lot of competition who probably don't
have as much experience and don't have
the same dedication to customer service
and quality like you do so how do you
stand out from everybody else and having
social proof and testimonials is a great
way to do it so pull whatever you know
one or two you like the best and maybe
not the whole thing with one key
sentence and put that
the homepage on this page I'd also try
to look at how can you maybe bold or
italic some of the the key points in
here because this it's a lot to read I
highlight a few key words like her
attention to detail work I think
whatever it is you feel is you really
helps you stand out the best point in
every paragraph bold and italics it so
it can somebody scanning this page and
quickly read through it and it also try
to put pictures of people so you're I
mean obviously you've gotten their
permission you have their name you have
their company it's easier to find out
about these people I'll just do a quick
search on their website or LinkedIn or
Google and if they have a picture put it
up with with the testimonials as well it
makes it friendly makes it more human
people spend a little bit longer on the
site looking at it so let's take one
let's take let's take Linda sick Linda
open up a new tab here we'll take Linda
from clutter be gone we'll do a quick
google search and see what comes up so
this looks like it's her there's Linda
and this is great you know she's got her
own site she's got a nice friendly
picture of her smiling right there in
the home page so i take that maybe
shrink it down a little bit and put it
right next to this so it helps make this
testament or stand out potentially even
linked to her site if you like if you're
trying to get more these kinds of
testimonials and customers from these
types of organizations then it's great
to be able to quickly see their website
and especially if you've had some kind
of impact like this is a this is a nice
layout on their website so are you
involved in updating this website at all
you know those types of things would be
great to show the testimonials are
awesome I probably also include some
case studies so let's see you have
something here on services which is
great I would try to put something here
on some examples of how you've helped so
it's awesome to have this what have you
done let's look at trade show so before
during and after if that's something
you're really trying to market maybe
show a link to an example with a
customer you've worked with hopefully
you can put their name but even if you
can't just put
to some information about them and what
you've done what the problem was how you
came in and help any kind of results
that have come from that so that if I'm
interested in having you come in and
help me with my trade shows now you're
standing up for everybody else right
because all the admitted having some
specific examples and showing a little
bit of the ROI as much as possible will
help make you stand out from everybody
else and hopefully make people want to
give you a call so those are my quick
early thoughts I think it's a great
service definitely needed just a few
ideas to help you maybe stand up from
everybody else who's offering the same
types of services so for everybody
watching if you liked the video please
give it a thumbs up below it makes you
want to do more of these for you and I'd
love to hear what you have to think
about this website or if you have a
question for your own business do if you
leave in the comments section below I
always read those it always makes my day
when when a new comment comes in so
thank you and we'll see you on the next
episode
you